hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar shield of
safety
protecting the clinical lab i am
michelle ashton of labrus
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar
is presented by labyrinths and brought
to you by lab conco corporation
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
ryan rios
vertical marketing manager lab concord
corporation
and jordan henderson product manager at
lab concord corporation ryan and jordan
you may now begin
your presentations
[Music]
welcome thank you to all of our
attendees for joining us today as we
celebrate medical lab professionals week
i'm ryan rios labconco's vertical
marketing manager
and i am joined today by labconco's
clinical lab scientist
and product manager jordan henderson
clinical lab professionals and
diagnostic testing are invaluable
components to ensuring the successful
treatment
of patients around the world diagnostic
excellence
and for improving the quality of patient
care overall
in 2019 studies suggest that 7 to 13
billion diagnostic tests were performed
contributing 106 billion to united
states gross domestic product
that's nearly 700 000 jobs in the united
states alone
with with diagnostic testing becoming
increasingly
more sensitive and prevalent quality of
the clinical lab and the safety of the
professional working in this setting are
subject
to ongoing process improvement
initiatives
today we'll provide a brief overview of
the clinical lab professionals role
their impact on patient safety trends of
the future
applications resources and regulations
as well as ways our customers are
maximizing safety and efficiency in
their daily work
first off what is diagnostic excellence
for the purpose of this webinar we pull
from a cited definition
diagnostic excellence is a systems level
state
that effectively integrates healthcare
knowledge skills and resources
for continuous and measurable
improvement
of diagnoses and reduction of risk or
occurrence of diagnostic errors
while continuing to meet overall needs
of
patients and health systems
by focusing on the reduction of risk
this allows for health systems to meet
the overall need of their patient
population
some of the trends and terms we're
hearing from our customers on diagnostic
excellence and the evolving role of the
clinical lab professional are called out
here
where this idea of diagnostic excellence
and the clinical lab intersect
is at the total life cycle of clinical
lab tests
first introduced in 1981
and coined as the total testing process
in 1986 by the centers for disease
control
this concept was only revisited again in
2011
and reinforced in 2013.
by leveraging the ideas of diagnostic
excellence in conjunction with the total
testing process
the clinical testing model can
essentially shift
towards an outcomes-based approach
rather than a volume model
we're able to observe the test life
cycle by interaction
setting and test phase the process
starts with the physician's
understanding of the patient's symptoms
to prompt the appropriate test order
and ends with the final interpretation
of the results by the physician
there are three phases pre-analytical
analytical and post-analytical
this process is also broken down by
setting from
lab setting to patient care setting
reports suggest the future of the
clinical lab professional
is one where they are integrated into
the process of providing diagnostic
excellence
rather than the more traditional siloed
approach three
what can happen when the clinical lab
heroes get involved
an increase in the ability for the
physician to make a proper diagnosis
for the patient as quickly as possible
as well as a considerable and measurable
reduction in diagnostic errors
future trends we are hearing from our
customers include
an increase in stewardship programs also
known as
anti-microbial stewardship or diagnostic
stewardship
these programs emphasize the role of the
clinical lab professional to maximize
patient outcomes and reduce costs with
comprehensive programs having
demonstrated an
annual savings of two hundred thousand
to nine hundred thousand dollars
other trends include new global
initiatives to increase
standardization the integration of
artificial intelligence into workflows
using multidisciplinary teams and taking
an evidence-based approach
to patient safety the increased need for
quality assurance tools and lab
management practices
increased knowledge sharing databases
where healthcare officials from around
the world can access their data
and continuous process improvement now
lab refresh
or lab professionals and continuous
process improvement
now lab professionals and clinical labs
in general are not strangers to process
improvement in quality measures
quite frankly the clinical lab is a
collection of ever-changing rules
regulations and standards that must be
met to achieve the necessary
accreditation
the culmination of this often appears as
various stewardship programs
or initiatives as we had mentioned
earlier
some of the potential outcomes of these
trends include
improved test utilization
leveraging clinical and laboratory data
effectively
promoting the effective use of credible
information resources
the use of diagnostic management teams
offering advanced clinical laboratory
degrees that support diagnostic
excellence
in quality measures and quality
management
now that i've shared some of the trends
and outcomes i'm going to hand this off
to jordan henderson as he'll dive into
the very important role of the clinical
lab in ensuring safe practices
specimen integrity end-user protection
as well as ways
our customers are using daily to
maximize their own safety and efficiency
smell right now
thank you ryan hi again my name is
jordan henderson
i'm the asp certified clinical
laboratory scientist
and product manager here at the lab
conco corporation
and obviously selecting clinical lab
equipment is very
important there are a number of
questions that need to be
answered when going through this process
the first question to be answered should
be what type of protection
are we looking to achieve do we need
personnel and product protection
do we just need product protection or do
we not need
either personnel or product protection
the next question to be asked is what
enclosure are we looking to work in
are they class 2 or class 1 bses
are they vertical clean benches or piece
or hepa filter pcr enclosures
or are they non-ventilated enclosures
next determining
the application that will be performed
in these enclosures is important
these workflows generally are very
specific to the apartments where the
these enclosures will be departments
such as microbiology
pathology histology molecular diagnostic
or are we collecting and preparing
samples or reagents
obviously answering those three
questions you'll be pushed towards a
certain product type
and then of course evaluating the need
for any additional accessories is
important as well
a prime example of this is storage of
potentially hazardous chemicals
in chemical cabinets
and the reason we have to go through
this process is because clinical
diagnostic
work inherently increases the potential
to expose
clinical lab workers to aerosolize
infectious or biohazardous material
so really having a better understanding
of how this equipment
protects you and provides a level of
safety is very important
to you maintaining a high quality of
of work and diagnostic excellence
so really the question at hand is a hood
is a hood right
when i first started off in my clinical
lab
experience i would have said yes
knowing what i know now that is the
short answer to that question is
no um here on the screen there are a
variety of hoods
um that all serve very different
functions and that have different
requirements and are
governed by different regulatory bodies
first i would like to take a step back
and answer the question of what is
biosafety
and its impact on the clinical lab
setting
the cdc has outlined what biosafety is
in their bmbl
they have established four different
levels
of biosafety each level of biosafety is
determined by the agent that is being
used
the activity level that's being
performed on that agent
this will dictate the the equipment
requirements
depending on what you're handling and
what activities you're performing
and then there is also a facility design
and construction component that goes
hand in hand with the specific bio
safety levels
so what do these specific levels look
like
bio level one can consist of work that
can be performed in an
open bench
generally you're handling non-pathogenic
organisms such as yeast
and non-infectious strands of e coli
such as the k-12 strand
really the only construction requirement
with the bsl level one
is that a sink is available for hand
washing
moving on to bsl level two this level
meets all
bsl level 1 requirements
but incorporates either a class 1 or
class 2
biological safety enclosure depending on
if sterility is needed or not
additionally personal protective
equipment ppe is required
to be in use in a bsl-2 level laboratory
oftentimes these bfl level 2
laboratories
will have access to an autoclave or
another decontamination
procedure
moving on to bsl level 3
again bsl level 3 meets all the
requirements of bsl level 2
however due to the agents that are being
handled
in these laboratory environments a
buffered corridor
must exist in these laboratories and
essentially this is just a shower in
shower out space
for laboratory workers to to
wash off and again further reduce
the exposure to aerosolized infectious
agents
this laboratory will have self-closing
doors
and the exhaust needs to work under
negative pressure
the most severe level of biosafety is
bsl level
4 and again it meets all vsl3 level
requirements
and oftentimes either either highly
restricted or entirely separate
buildings with their own dedicated
plumbing
and other utility lines
the type of dsc that can be used in this
in conjunction with positive pressure
suits as indicated in the image to the
left
or a class 1 or class 2 bsc
or a class 3 bfc
if they're not using positive pressure
pressure suits
an example of a class 3 bfc
is going to be a laminar flow glove box
that is a totally enclosed
and is leak tight
so i'd like to talk about bio safety
cabinets
my bio safety cabinets essentially
exists to protect laboratory workers
such as
medical lab scientists as yourself and
their surrounding environments
from exposure to aerosolized infectious
material
by incorporating filters in these
cabinets
that is how these these enclosures help
track those particulates and aerosols
by doing so this allows for more complex
procedures to be
done more safely and efficiently
so to understand a little bit more of
how these
biosafety cabinets operate we need to
understand what laminar or
unidirectional airflow is
so really what laminar airflow is
is air moving in a uniform direction at
a uniform velocity
why is this important is because that
uniform direction of airflow
under that uniform velocity helps sweep
biohazardous material away which
controls contamination
and by manipulating those airflow
patterns just a little bit more we're
able to provide sterile environments to
work in
on this slide here is just a
representation of the air flow patterns
in a class 2 a2 bfc
inward air is pulled through the sash
opening towards the rear baffle
where the blower then redirects it
towards the top of the unit
that inward airflow is offering that
personnel protection
once the air is pushed through a hepa
filter
in a downward fashion that air is then
used to provide product protection that
we're looking for
exhausted air is also pushed through a
hepa filter
which provides clean air to the to the
environment that that lab tech is
working in
so to go a little bit deeper in bio
safety cabinets
they are broken into classes there are
three classes class one class
two and class three for the most part
class two bscs are going to be commonly
found in the clinical laboratory
they are further subdivided into types
and the most common types that we will
find in a clinical lab are going to be
your a1s and your a2s
this bsc offers personnel product
and environmental protection for
microbiol
microbiological workflows and processes
again as i had mentioned previously the
inward air flow is responsible for
protecting the end user or the medical
lab professional
the downward hepa filtered laminar
airflow
is responsible for protecting your
samples and products
from contamination and then the hepa
filtered exhaust air
is going to be recirculated
back into the environment
when it comes to contaminated ductworks
and plenums
just please note that these need to be
operated under a negative pressure to
further reduce
exposure risk risk of aerosolized
infectious material
here's another representation of the
anticipated airflow
in a type type 2 a2 bsc
the picture on the right is just showing
again
airflow being sucked in through the sash
opening being redirected
through the back plenum uh via the
blower
and forced either through two filters
one to exhaust or one to provide that
downward airflow
for product protection the image on the
left
is indicating really
the work area and work surface due to
these type 2 or i'm sorry class 2 type
a2
bscs recirculating air it's not
recommended that
um chemicals are are used
just so after recirculating
hazardous chemicals um they could
concentrate and cause
problems so just be aware of that
um you can't talk bs without talking
hepa filters and hepa filters are high
efficiency particulate air filters
that consist of four components the
filter media the frame
the bonding agent and the gasket these
filters are 99.9
effective at filtering out particulates
at a
0.3 micron size
this allows us to provide iso class 5 or
better
air and of course as i mentioned before
all bses are com come with two
two hepa filters one to filter the
supply air
one to filter the exhaust there
when it comes to bio safety resources as
i mentioned the cdc
and the cdc's bl bmbl
fifth edition is a great resource in
understanding what biosafety is and how
to handle potentially infectious agents
i provided a link here for reference in
the future
or if you're just interested in what the
cdc thinks about this
when it comes to the design requirements
of class 2 bses
the nsf standard 49 is going to be
a great resource to look at in
understanding
the design requirements for biological
safety cabinets
additional bio safety resources
the controlled environment testing
association or ceta
is going to be responsible for the
exhaust system requirements for class
2bses
there is a fee associated with this one
i've provided the link below
other important resources to be aware of
are the world health organization which
is free
absa uh in it that
nih uh which is also free and then of
course
the canadian bioscience i'm sorry bio
safety standards and guidelines as well
so where are these products found in the
laboratory
my first experience when i started my
clinical lab journey
was in microbiology biological safety
cabinets
serves as an ideal workstation for the
numerous
microbiology workflows that are done
every day
these workflows include setting up test
cli test kits
such as flu ab rsv rapid testing
fecal occults or other molecular test
kits like
rapid flu a b testing
setting up and drying grand stained
slides prior to staining
and then this also gives us a workspace
to streak microbiology plates
for later identification and
susceptibility testing as well
another solution that is commonly found
throughout the lab
is going to be a filtered pcr enclosure
essential essentially this solution is
just a vertical clean bench
that protects your work area the reason
why this is important
is because obviously when you're doing
pcr testing or other nucleic acid
amplification testing
really limiting the contamination risk
is important because as you know
when contaminants are amplified it just
throws your entire runs off
however it should be noted that
the type of airflow that's provided only
provides
product protection it does not protect
the end user
so great care needs to be taken when
evaluating the use of these
solutions if you are using biohazardous
material
various toxins or other radionucleotides
potentially
we don't recommend this solution at all
so again careful assessment is required
to make sure everyone is being
being considered and things are done
safely and effectively
oftentimes these solutions will come
with uv lights incorporated in with them
obviously when we're dealing with rna
and dna
the presence of them poses a risk of
contamination so
incorporating uv light actually
decontaminates
um residual dna that's left over
to again provide a level
of safety and efficiency when using
these products
so where do we find these pcr enclosures
in the lab
well obviously the molecular department
is going to be an ideal situation for
for these products again
for workflows pcr or
nucleic acid the amplification testing
that
still incorporate a pretty manual micro
micro
well um plating procedure this is going
to be a place where that's going to be
carried out
moving on to another solution that's
commonly found within the laboratory
environment are going to be your
duckless carbon filtered enclosures
oftentimes
these are just referred to as ductless
hoods
and the reason why is because they serve
as viable alternatives to their
traditional ducted hoods
these solutions are going to give you
the ability to work with volatile
chemicals and vapors
they can handle nuisance odonts and
non-toxic chemicals
and then they can also be used in
non-toxic
to handle non-toxic particulates as well
really the regulatory body that's
responsible for the divine
defining this is going to be fifa and
we are guided by fifa 9-2
the fifa 9-2010 ductless hood
classification is going to be
responsible for three classifications of
ductless hoods the first classification
is dh1 this is just stating that
ductless hoods should be designed
to filter non-toxic chemicals nuisance
odors and particulates
moving on to dh2 this level meets all
the dh1 requirements
but is equipped with the filtration able
to handle an approved
toxic contaminants up to a break
breakthrough point only moving on to dh
level
3 this meets all the dh level 2
requirements
and is equipped with the filtration
mechanism to handle approved toxic
contaminants
up to and beyond their breakthrough
point
via secondary filter
so why would a clinical lab want to
incorporate ductless hoods
into their clinical lab setting
obviously not being hard ducted to
existing ductwork provides a level of
flexibility that hospitals
routinely sync and require oftentimes
these
clinical laboratories are put in lower
levels of hospitals
or they're in older buildings that it's
just hard to
modify existing ductwork
again not being ducted to existing
ductwork
makes it for a very easy installation
process
and it is associated with reduced cost
by streamlining the installation process
obviously not being fixed means these
things are more portable
so they can move room to room to
accommodate
um whether departments move or workflows
need to be
done in a different environment
these are sustainable obviously ducted
hoods don't have
makeup air requirements and finally
ducted hoods uh
tend to be less green so an inducted uh
ductless hood
actually doesn't vent uh conditioned air
which is saving um
money as well one uh so where are
ductless hoods gonna be found in the
clinical laboratory
the first place that i see dr douglas
hoods
in the clinical laboratory is going to
be the pathology department
and often it's going to be during the
tissue grossing
segment of pathological workflows
obviously because
those specimens are transported
and preserve it as ductless hoods are
going to be an ideal
spot to manage those odors and chemicals
additionally you can find ductless hoods
in the cytology and histology
departments
during the tissue staying process um
those chemicals
can have strong odors and ductless are
ideal to manage that as well
but when it comes to cover slipping
ductless hoods
can be utilized here as well um because
of the phosphate
buffer formula and preservative for
storage of these slides
um ducted hoods are are are an ideal
solution to handle those odors
so we've discussed a number of solutions
a number of
regulations that that should be
considered
who's responsible for really leveraging
all this information
that's where the biosafety officer comes
in
the role of the biosafety officer is
important because they're directly
responsible for developing safety
policies and procedures they're going to
be responsible for training of
laboratory staff
to make sure that they're following
the established procedures to ensure
their safety as well
they'll also consult in advising on from
a safety perspective throughout the
laboratory
they also ensure compliance with the
safety policies and procedures
they will assist and perform regular
safety inspections to make sure
everything is up
up to par they will investigate and
document
laboratory accidents and report on those
accidents as well
in my experience as a clinical lab
professional
this role was consisted of
multiple people oftentimes clinical
coordinators or department supervisors
really understanding the workflows and
what is required of them
from a diagnostic perspective in
conjunction with
building managers and environmental
service managers
to make sure that the mechanical
mechanical components
are being considered as well so this
concludes the end of the presentation
and i'd like to say thank you
future of healthcare and patient safety
is paramount to our well-being
that is as is the ability to provide
accurate and timely test results
safely and affordably while also
minimizing risk and improving the lives
of patients around the world your role
in this equation is crucial
so today we thank you and recognize that
you are the hidden heroes behind
successful patient outcome so for more
solutions in regards to the clinical
laboratory environment
please visit labconco.com clinical
i would like to open the floor for any
questions
that any attendees may have at this
moment
thank you ryan and jordan for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started
let's see
our first question is what
features of lab equipment should i be
looking for
to maximize efficiency in the molecular
lab setting
um so that's a good question obviously
when it comes to the molecular testing
like i said a little bit ago
it's really limiting the the presence of
any potential contaminants because
obviously you know when you do
pcr testing or nucleic acid testing when
we start to amplify things
contaminants uh tend to get amplified as
well
and so when those contaminants are
present and they get amplified obviously
that can throw a wrench into the quality
of your results
additionally
having to redo testing is time consuming
energy consuming
and cost consuming so it's very
important to have an enclosure that can
really manage
uh to provide that that quality working
environment
and that's where those pcr enclosures
come
come from so obviously pulling in hepa
filter
downward flowing laminar air is going to
be responsible really
offering that product protection that
that you need when it comes to those
sensitive
molecular workflows
thank you jordan that's great all right
this next
question is what is the ideal
environment
for work with covid19 samples and why
uh so this is um you know a pretty
common question that
um that a lot of people have been asking
obviously this past year
um from a clinical lab perspective
um we need to consider the types of
specimens that can be contaminated so
you obviously have your
respiratory specimens like sputum your
whole blood your serum your plasma
or potentially even urine specimens
all of these should of course be handled
as withstand
in the assumption of standard
precautions at the
level 2 biosafety level
and specifically like some workflows
working with intact or full full length
genomic rna that's going to be done in a
bsl level 2 laboratory under those
those recommendations um also worth
mentioning that
any activities involving manipulation of
untreated specimens can also be
performed in a bsl level 2 facility
while using bsl
3 practices when it comes to
more of a research side so cell
propagation
um from culture i'm sorry propagation in
cell cultures
uh and even just the initial
identification or characterization
of um coping 19 samples
and their recovery actually should be
performed uh
at the biosafety three level so
okay great thank you all right your next
question
given the fluctuation and overwhelming
nature of the pandemic
on the healthcare system what should i
be looking for
in the future in order to lessen
diagnostic errors
and maximize efficiency
thank you great question i would say
over the past year we're really seeing
as the biggest opportunity for success
would be quality control
and management you've got to stay safe
you've got to ask the right questions at
the right time and as you all
especially know incredibly fluid
circumstances require you to be very
adaptable
though the nature of your work is one
that is
based on your results and the quality of
those results and so in order to produce
quality test results amid such chaos as
the pandemic has presented us educate
yourselves daily
and just focus on quality control and
management and adapting and learning
every day
based on what we you know we're learning
great thank you uh let's see are there
other regulations we should be
aware of that are important
absolutely so when it comes to
regulations um here in the states
especially
uh when it comes to laboratory
accreditation uh a
cap college of american pathologist is
is gonna be
be a heavy hitter obviously being
responsible for
inheriting a variety of regulations and
metrics to be met but also providing
that road map
is something that clinical labs are
concerned with every
every day other other
regulations include astm iso
clsi other regulatory bodies include
clea the cms or the center for medicare
and medicaid services
and then also clsi because they're an
international organization looking to
add standardization across all
all clinical workflows um so
there you could talk forever about the
regulations and and
what the clinical lab has has to work
through or adhere to
until you're blue in the face that's for
sure
but really it's always just important to
be aware
again educate yourself on the changes
i know i did say that i gave you a
reference to the
cdc bmbl that's actually they just came
out with the sixth edition
so so that's how fast something can
change like that
so so yeah just always being aware of
the the various collection of
regulations and regulatory bodies
is definitely a challenge and that the
clinical lab has to deal with
okay this next question is simple and to
the point i know i need a hood where do
i start
great question we get that a lot there
i admit i would just i would really
recommend picking up the phone and
starting with a conversation to maximize
your own time spent looking for
equipment
there are canned questions such as you
know that jordan went through what are
your protection levels and requirements
needed do you need protection for
yourself and for the sample is it just
for you
is it just for the product as well as
your application
which it needs to be account accounted
for whether or not that might change for
the future because your application now
might not be the same as in the future
and you may
therefore need a level of flexibility
that you wouldn't
otherwise need so i would i would start
with a phone call to try to figure out
um what the best enclosure would be to
ensure safety for
for you as well as for the lab and your
product
thank you it looks like we have another
question here
would you include laboratory and safety
and decreased
lab acquired infections as an outcome
um yeah so absolutely
laboratory-inquired infections are
always important especially when
when considered respiratory
viruses that can aerosolize so when you
think of that you think obviously covid
but
the the pretty standard talking point on
that would have been um your tb
uh precautions that you can take always
tracking those things
um is important and that should be a
main focus um
because and i know obviously clinical
labs we often
only hear of hospital acquired
infections from
a collection standpoint or just a
surgery standpoint for like
mrsa uh stewardship programs and things
like that
but laboratory acquired infections and
is a real thing and it needs to be taken
seriously to really ensure that
end users feel safe to do their job and
that they're not being
inadvertently exposed to extremely
hazardous infectious
agents like tb so
okay well that is all the time we have
for today i know there are a few
questions
left we will make sure that we follow up
with you via email
following the broadcast so thank you
again ryan and jordan for your time
today
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor lab congo for
underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye